was geht ab hier ist ghani und herzlich
kommen zu diesem neuen video wir werden
heute mal etwas ganz neues machen und
zwar habe ich dieses handy das an diesem
kabel hängt und das hängt wiederum an
dieser ergab die mir die jungs von
elgato ford jeweils zugeschickt haben
dann ist es schon lange in video damit
machen wollen und mir zeit gelassen aber
jetzt werden wir etwas gutes machen wir
gehen einfach in die charts und wir
werden gucken was können wir spielen
aber kostenlose chart so leute wir
werden uns jetzt drei spiele aussuchen
von dem wir keine ahnung haben wie es
geht und wir haben jeweils einen
versucht sie zu spielen wie wär's mit
swing swing letztes so erste apps will
geht runter wir gucken weiter so kennen
wir schon mal nicht die lust gehabt dann
machen wir's nicht spielen kann ich
hab's anderen gespielt und subway
service nochmals ist noch irgendwas was
aber cool basketball vorsieht auch
basketballer vollkommen okay dann haben
wir jetzt drei apps ausgewählt und wir
gucken gleich meine erste rein
ich würde einfach mal vorschlagen als
bestrafung kriegt der verlierer
als frau muss es sein dass behinderte
idee total beschissen
der süße ganze dusche den tisch ist auch
schlimm einfach so darfst dir so ein
handfestes dem dem ein punkt also ich
würde sagen ich fange mit dem ersten
spiel an
wahrscheinlich kennen ganz viel von euch
schon denkt ist okay wie schlecht sind
surfer step to play
zwei meter hoch über dem labor 28
wieso kann ich einfach runterfallen
auch jetzt wird richtig schnell
ich weiß nicht ob ich schnell bin oder
surfen ich bin da kann da muss in drei
versuchen kein drei versuche einfach ein
versuch ein versuch ok muss immer
probieren die wellen sozusagen
anzupassen auf die höhe
hat er also einen richtig chilligen
anfang gab der essen war unser bester
mann des lebens maschine wissen darüber
gemacht
er wüsste hoch aber du hast mich im
ersten spiel besiegt 32 damit geht der
erste punkt an dich jetzt spielen wir
basket von anfang ich aber am ampelmast
vor die diesmal fängst du an genau wir
sind ja schon ein bisschen gefehlt in
der app legt einfach los die funktion
die steuerung unten schnell 1 punkt wenn
du über ein punkt ist ein punkt
ich habe es gleich verstanden egal wo du
[ __ ] wirklich wird die spur
geschnitten und muss also gucken zum
beispiel jetzt ja kinder auch okay ist
er ist aber ein versuch wollte dass man
unentschieden okay das war's dann wird
es halt immer schnell das eigentlich
cool wenn ich jetzt läuft bei masten
hast du sechs punkte wenn du drei
geworden ist hält sie an der korb bewegt
sich jetzt nein das hat mich erwischt
also irgendwie gibt es schlicht punkte
aber ich habe sechs strikt eigentlich
weil wenn ich jetzt fragte hast du schon
gewonnen jetzt alle macht über die junge
das ein schlechtes spiel finde ich da
auf zig leute und wenn man den keulen an
sondern kriegt man extra points
erscheinen
der recall aber nicht vergessen dass man
denkt zweiter un führt mit der
bestrafung eigentlich ne gute idee mit
dem wasser gar nicht schlecht okay wir
machen doppelt oder nicht zwei duschen
oder keine
was ist wenn ich jetzt verliere dann
kriege ich auch nicht 22 und jetzt okay
leute spielen
okay okay ein flottes schwerstens
koffer24 ich kann schon das ist schon
eher so ein geschäft vor allem diese
ganze netz wo du einfach nur für kakteen
wie sie zum ersten mal spielst
das ist ja schwer mit mit
höhendifferenzen alter die app liegt mir
vollmann
du sollst nicht so gewinnen die app
liegt mir nicht ganz gereicht
leute was habe ich mir ein gebot der
bestrafung diebe grad eben noch wollt
welche war zumindest in pully
das nicht sein muss machen cool und dann
wirst du mir ins gesicht ist orte sind
das hat sogar fort micro kaputt alles
kaputt
ja leute hier mit der reflexion special
ja da sieht man es so schaut das aus
leute hier ist die game capture susie
neckar und die tastatur ist auch schon
lassen
dann habe ich es hat euch gefallen wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder